dane dunning this will be his 12th start
more strikeouts than innings about three
walks per nine innings
numbers are pretty good the one thing
he's done he's limited the home run ball
he's only given up four home runs in 52
innings that's a good number
the 2-2 on the way breaking ball struck
him out looking
then he went to the curve ball there
it's his least frequently used pitch
out of the five pitches he features and
he buckled the knees around the
rosarina to get the strikeout to the
pitch
a check swing roller out in front of the
plate dunning off the mound to field it
globs to first for the out
and it's a scoreless first inning today
for dane dunning
no runs no hits one left michael walker
this year
he's pitched in relief and he's started
i think one thing that he's probably
done a little more often than he would
like is give up the home run ball he's
giving up six home runs in 35
innings holt at third kinder for left
head first
low left-handed batter against the
righty and the pitch low hits a ground
ball to second base
glove there by lao to walls for one to
first a double play
the rangers score a run as the rays get
two outs and the first inning drought
has come to an end
after 19 games without scoring in the
first inning
the rangers get a run in the first
inning today
center field phillips is there and after
one
it's the rangers one and the raise
nothing also switch hitter betting 216
overall hits
only 167 from this side of the plate
as the pitch is swinging this one is a
looper up towards center field and it's
going to settle in
for a base hit so taylor walls who's
been swinging the bat
pretty well here over the last few days
picks up a one-out single
that's a lighter and a left at a base
set
two men aboard with one out walls
advancing to second
and he got it just over the head of
counterfeit chance for the raise to
maybe tie this game up they're down one
nothing
here on the top of the second inning one
nothing rangers lead and the pitch is
lifted high in the air to short left
field
calhoun coming on and toward the line
willie's there makes a one-handed catch
just off the left shoulder and there are
two outs brandon lau would be next
rangers lead one nothing
and the pitch is swung on and missed he
struck him out got him with a slider and
that ends the inning
no runs two hits and two men left after
an inning and a half the rangers lead
one nothing
charlie culverson hitting two 23 three
homers
well he gets a chase there on the 30th
pitch of the
outing he started high and went higher
and higher and higher
and culverson counted that plate in
swing mode so one out one on and here's
jason martin
now the pitch on its way to martin swung
out and lifted in the air to left center
field
pushing back brett phillips but he's got
room in front of the track makes the
catch
tagging at first was calhoun then he
hits the brakes and stays there
and so martin hit it well but phillips
ran it down and there's two gone
you wonder if this might be his last
batter with the left-hander sheriff
warming in the bullpen it's here's a
swing and a ground ball right into the
shift and brandon lowens short right
throws the first quickly and that will
take care of jonah heim
and the rangers here on the second and
we've got one out here in the top of the
third one pitch one out
2-2 pitch here swing and a miss
good-looking breaking pitch there from
dane dunning and he strikes out arroza
reina for a second time
wendell hitting just 167 over his last
eight games however in the week and a
half prior to that
he was on fire and over the course of
his last 17 overall he's actually
hitting 323.
2-2 pitch on the way swinging a miss
goodhart slider down and in will get
windall
and it's a one two three inning here for
dane dunning his first today
long set of times here for mejia and the
pitch on the way
swinging he popped him up back of the
plate but running out of room
here and he's there and he makes the
catch
hard to tell without being there we have
zero depth perception but
you know he casually went back to it i
think he must have seen it early and
recognized how much room and time he had
to get there
two and two-thirds for michael walker
today and he allows one run
next pitch low flares it out into left
center and it falls for the base hit
but rosarina to pick it up nate low goes
the opposite way
with a two out single here off of cheryl
ground ball right to second base and to
his left is brandon low and he throws
out soloq and
even with the hit and walk aloud ryan
sheriff gets out of it well the reyes
haven't gotten a run yet off dane
dunning this year he's thrown seven
scoreless so here's an opportunity
it's about time it is about time yandee
diaz grounded his short his first time
up he wants to avoid that here
swinging a miss here by diaz on that
slider which has been a very good pitch
today for dame dunning and diaz is out
on strike
the fifth strikeout victim short lead at
first for meadows as dunning scents
kicks and deals
and here's a ground ball near conor
falefa he feels it steps on second for
one throws the first double play
to get out of the inning so the rays get
a leadoff single from meadows but he's
rubbed out
on the six unassisted 6-3 twin killing
here come the rangers 2-1 nobody out
now sheriff pitches breaking ball swung
on the missed strike three got him on
three pitches
and it would have been a strike a little
spinner towards the inside part of the
plate
and three pitches sheriff gets his first
strikeout finally gets the lefty two
texas with a slim lead but two one and
one out on the home forward sheriff
pitches
swing and a miss he struck him out looks
like a cunter in on the hands
and heim is retired sheriff is not a big
strikeout pitcher
but he's gotten back-to-back case a
glance to second
and the pitch swinging he popped him up
should get him out of the ending at the
shallow center
taylor walls drifting out come along
brett phillips who calls him off and
catches it
to retire the side so well done by ryan
sheriff back-to-back hits to begin the
inning and then gets the next three
hitters
well the reigns are going to see a
left-hander as we go to the
sixth inning randy rosarina will lead
off followed by
wendell and then meadows and taylor
hearn
will take over making his 18th
appearance
2-2 to a rose arena and that's drilled
to center field but coming on
to make the catch is jason martin one
down one-nothing
texas leading there's a swing and a fly
ball to center
back to grab this one is martin
oh martin with four put outs on the day
three in the last two innings
the rangers lead one nothing in here is
meadows who has seen the comebacker and
singled to extend his hitting streak to
10 games here's the pitch
strike three call a one two three ending
for taylor hearn he rings up meadows on
a fast ball
after five and a half the rangers lead
the raise one nothing
two balls two strikes to walls the pitch
swinger line drive down the left field
line that's in for a base hit
and it skips on the turf and goes all
the way into the corner
walls is around first and into second he
rounds it and holds on
as calhoun gets it back in and taylor
walls has a double the raise
of the tying run into scoring position
margot one for two
he swings and pops one up high into the
air near second base
kiner falefa calling for it and he makes
the catch by his left shoulder
this is his second pinch hitting
appearance he walked his other tongue
the one one is hit on the ground to
third holt is there he's got it goes to
second they get the force on mejia
and that will end the tampa bay threat
here in the seventh there are two
men out now but an insurance run just 90
feet away
now the pitch swinging a soft liner to
straight away center charging caremeyer
still coming off slides and makes the
catch to retire the side
pump of the fist for jp fire eisen and
that thing
almost blooped in and for a guy that's
leading the american league in hits
he's gotten his share of those i'm sure
the bases are loaded
for austin meadows the raised top run
producer
here's the pitch that one is popped up
on the first base side
low and foul ground appears to have a
play
and he's called off by culverson who
makes the catch wow
there is a big out to get austin meadows
one away in the eighth bases loaded for
tampa bay
one out and josh spores 27 year old
right hander on the pitch
the three ball two strike pitch it's
high ball four and the rays have tied
the game
a bases loaded walk brings in brandon
lau and it's a 1-1 game in the eighth
gets the sunny light so the one-two
pitch to walls
is now on its way swinging a line drive
up the middle base hitting this center
field
a rose arena scores russo rounding third
on his way home and he will score taylor
walls with a two-run single
and the rays take a 3-1 lead in the
eighth he stands at second kirameir
third a basic could really open this up
for the raise
and the pitch is sliced into left field
and it's going to get down for a hit
jeremiah scores here's brasso throw to
the plate too late
it's a two out two rbi single by austin
meadows and the rays
have opened this one up they take a five
one lead here in the ninth
now the left-hander again ready to go in
the pitch minus witty yandy is swinging
and lifted in the air
left field and deep calhoun going back
does he have enough
it's gone yandi diaz with his first
home run of 20-21 two more runs come
home for the raise
it's 7-1 now fairbanks is on with
pretty good numbers except for the walks
he's walked eight in 13 innings
settles in and the pitch on its way
swing and a miss
he struck him out the raise win ray's
win
ray's win